[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halallweg guten Abend ihnen
allen Norbert König ist auch wieder
dabei für den Sport guten Abend auch am
vierten Tag nach dem beispiellosen
Terrorangriff der Hamas überlagert der
Krieg dort fast alles
andere unendliches Leid auf beiden
Seiten die Hamas grei in Israel an
dessen Armee bereitet sich auf eine
Bodenoffensive
vor raus aus dem Kriegsgebiet tausende
Deutsche versuchen Israel zu verlassen
stoßen dabei aber auch auf
Hindernisse alarmierender Vorfall in der
Ostsee eine Gaspipeline zwischen Estland
und Finnland wurde offenbar beschädigt
unklar von
wem Israel ist ins Mark getroffen die
Zahl der Opfer steigt immer weiter die
hat bei ihren Terrorattacken mehr als
1000 Menschen getötet und 150 entführt
und Israel schlägt zurück mit intensiven
Luftangriffen alle vier Stunden auf den
gazaastreifen die Heimat der Hamas auch
dort sterben Zivilisten die
Palästinenser sprechen von fast 800
Toten und 4000
verletzten israel hat den gesamten
Gazastreifen abgeriegelt auch der
Grenzübergang bei Raffa nach Ägypten ist
inzwischen geschlossen darüber wurden
unter anderem humanitäre Hilfsgüter nach
Gaza gebracht eine Bodenoffensive der
israelischen Armee scheint nur eine
Frage der Zeit zu sein 25 Grenzorte auf
israelischer Seite wurden fast komplett
evakuiert lck walpot
berichtet ganze Raketen Salven feuerte
die Hamas auch heute wieder aus dem
Gazastreifen auf israelische Städte ab
Detonationen waren zu hören die meisten
Geschosse wurden von Israels
Abwehrschirm neutralisiert
zwar hat die Armee die grenznahen Orte
wieder unter Kontrolle doch kam es 2 km
nördlich der Grenze zu einem
Feuergefecht heute mit vier Terroristen
die sich dort versteckt hielten sie
seien außer Gefecht gesetzt worden hieß
es Israels Vergeltungsschläge auf Ziele
in Gaza werden unterdessen weiter
intensiviert Tag und Nacht die Zahl der
Opfer steigt mehr als 180.000 Menschen
haben nach Behördenangaben ihre Wohnung
verloren eine Versorgungskrise auch die
Krankenhäuser sind völlig überlastet es
fehlen Medikamente und Strom den Israel
abgestellt
hat wir laufen jetzt ohne Strom hier im
Notbetrieb neben den Verwundeten
versuchen wir aber trotzdem weiter mit
Mühe vor allem chronisch Kranke wie
Dialysepatienten oder auch die
Entbindungsstation weiter zu
versorgen der UN Hochkommissar für
Menschenrechte kriier te Israels
Abriegelung des Gazastreifens Israel
wies diese Kritik scharf zurück man habe
das Recht sich gegen die Brutalität der
Terroristen zu wehren die Geiselnahme
israelischer Zivilisten durch Hamas und
die Drohung diese Menschen als
Schutzschilde einzusetzen nannte der
Hochkommissar ein Kriegsverbrechen
unterdessen verschaffen sich israelische
Sicherheitskräfte ein Bild über das
Ausmaß der Terrorattacke in den
grenznahen Dörfern wie hier in quasa wo
zahlreiche Familien mit Kindern von der
Hamas ermordet wurden
die sehen doch selbst das waren Mütter
Väter Babys in 40 Jahren Militärdienst
habe ich so etwas nie gesehen das ist
kein Krieg das ist Terror
über das Schicksal der mehr als 100
Geiseln in der Hand der Hamas ist weiter
nichts
bekannt Michael bberunge ist in
Aschkelon wo die Hamas heute ein
Ultimatum gestellt hatte die Bewohner
sollen sich bis sollen bis zum
Nachmittag die Stadt verlassen was ist
passiert
also wir sind jetzt seit 17 Uhr Ortzeit
seit dem Ablauf dieses Ultimatums in
Aschkelon haben seitdem acht
Angriffswellen mit Raketen gezählt auch
heftige Angriffswellen aber das war
jetzt nicht der große Vernichtungsschlag
den man vielleicht hinter einem solchen
Ultimatum hätte vermuten können es gab
zwar Einschläge aber keine größeren
Schäden weitus schwerer durfte das
Problem im Süden wiegen die Armee hatte
ja wir haben es im Beitrag gehört heute
morgen verkündet man habe die Kontrolle
über den Süden wiedererlangt aber dann
gibt es doch immer wieder Berichte dass
es Gefechte mit einzelnen hamaskämpfn
gibt und Netanyahu der Premierminister
hat klargestellt das erste Ziel muss
sein die Kontrolle im Süden vollständig
wiederzugewinnen erst dann kann er die
angekündigte große beispiellose
Offensive gegen den Gazastreifen führen
welchen Rückhalt hat die Hammers im
Gazastreifen stehen die Menschen hinter
den
Aktionen
das ist natürlich eine Frage die man
jetzt und von hier aus nicht seriös
beantworten kann es gibt keine
Meinungsumfragen Gaza ist eine
islamistische Diktatur die von Hamas und
islamischer Jihad regiert wird die
Menschen können sich nicht frei äußern
als ich vor zi Jahren nach dem Krieg
damals dem längeren zweiwöchigen Krieg
im gazerastreifen war und mit Menschen
dort gesprochen habe gab es sehr großen
Unmut und nicht uneingeschränkten Rück
für die Hamas und ich glaube man muss
auch jetzt sagen ohne es genau zu wissen
man kann nicht die Taten die jetzt hier
die Terroristen in am Wochenende hier in
Israel verübt haben
automatisch gleichsetzen mit der
Verantwortung die vielleicht die
Menschen in Gasa dafür haben die werden
sicherlich nicht alle daavon unterstützt
werden gleich wohl führen natürlich auch
die massiven Bombenangriffe der Israelis
zu einem Solidarisierungseffekt vielen
Dank für diese Einschätzung live aus
Aschkelon Michael
beverunge beim terrorüberfall der Hamas
auf Israel gab es auch deutsche Opfer
die genaue Zahl der Toten Verletzten und
verschleppten ist aber noch unklar
inzwischen hat auch der General
Bundesanwalt Ermittlungen gegen die
Hamas aufgenommen unter anderem wegen
Geiselnahme und Mord nach ZDF
Informationen ist unter den Todesopfern
eine 22-jährige deutsche Studentin
mindestens fünf Bundesbürger sollen sich
in der Gewalt der Hamas
befinden die deutsche Shani Luk die von
Terroristen bewusstlos auf einem Pickup
verschleppt wurde ist nach Angaben ihrer
Mutter am Leben sie soll mit schweren
Kopfverletzungen in einer Klinik im
Gazastreifen liegen sie gehört zu den
Menschen die die Terroristen bei einem
Musikfestival in der Nähe des Ortes Reim
etwa 5 km vom Gazastreifen überfielen
sie ermordeten dort mehr als 270
Menschen die Berichte der Augenzeugen
von diesem Festival sind erschütternd
eine junge Portugiesin war dabei und hat
den Kollegen von CNN davon erzählt
Christoph desterell fasst
zusammen Michal Ohana hat überlebt warum
ausgerechnet sie kann die 27-Jährige
nicht erklären nur beschreiben wie es
passierte um 6 Uhr morgens sei die Party
noch gelaufen plötzlich Sirenen der
übliche Luftalarm hätten alle gedacht
bis die hammerskämpfer
kamen
sie schossen uns ab wie auf einem
Schießplatz wer konnte rannte um sein
Leben andere wurden
getötet Michal und ihr Freund versuchen
mit einem Auto zu fliehen geraten in den
nächsten Kugelhagel wieder zu Fuß
schaffen sie es gerade so in einen
herumstehenden
Wohnwagen da waren schon rund 50 von uns
drin viele mit Schusswunden in Beinen im
Rücken bei manchen im Kopf ich hatte
einen Schal neben mir blutete eine Frau
mit dem Schal Band ich ihr das Bein ab
draußen kurzgespenstische Ruhe drin
verzweifeltes hoffen doch dann feuern
die hammerskämpfer direkt auf den
Wagen plötzlich schrie die Polizistin
die bei uns war wer überleben will der
rennt jetzt los wer konnte rante also
ich weiß nicht was aus den anderen wurde
sie rennt kann nicht mehr bekommt Panik
ihr Freund schleppt sie weiter hilft ihr
durchs offene Fenster in ein
vorbeikommendes Auto doch überall
drumrum die
Hammers mit pickup trucks auf jedem
mindestens 20 Terroristen mit
Kalaschnikows Schrotflinten
Maschinengewehren wieder zu Fuß schafft
sie es bis zu einem aufgegebenen
israelischen Panzer bekommt dort einen
Schuss ins Bein schrabnell in den Bauch
doch niemand Zert sie aus ihrem Versteck
während andere verschleppt werden 6
Stunden kauert Michal unter dem Panzer
dann kommen israelische Soldaten zur
Hilfe die EU Außenminister haben sich in
einer Krisensitzung mit der Lage im
Nahen Osten befasst dabei ging es unter
anderem darum ob die EU und die
Mitgliedstaaten Hilfsprogramme für die
Palästinenser weiter finanzieren sollen
dazu gab es gestern widersprüchliche
Informationen beim deutschfranzösischen
Treffen in Hamburg haben Bundeskanzler
Scholz und Präsident macron einen
völligen Stopp der humanitären Hilfen
abgelehnt die Zivilbevölkerung müsse
Wasser und Nahrungsmittel
erhalten fragen wir fröller in Brüssel
wo steht die EU jetzt wird sie die
Menschen im Gazastreifen weiter
unterstützen also die Sitzung der EU
auusminister ist gerade zu Ende gegangen
und es gibt drei wichtige Botschaften
die erste ist dass die überwiegende
Mehrheit der europäischen Außenminister
sagt die Entwicklungshilfe an die
Palästinenser muss weiterlaufen man will
gucken wo die Gelder hingehen dass nicht
z Mast kommt aber man sagt das hätter
man auch vorher schon gemacht zweitens
die PLO soll sich mit alt mit entschloss
heit von der Hamas distanzieren und die
Anschläger verurteilen und drittens und
das war allen sehr sehr wichtig in der
Sitzung zu betonen dass die humanitäre
Hilfe jetzt in den Gazastreifen eben
wichtiger ist denn je weil diese
Angriffe laufen und es muss
sichergestellt sein oder gesorgt werden
dafür dass es medizinische Versorgung
gibt ein Außenminister hat mir gesagt
europa muss verstehen und klar machen
dass die 2 Millionen Menschen die im
Gazastreifen Leben eben nicht
Terroristen sind sondern viele von ih
Opfer vom Terrorismus der Hamas und nur
wenn es diese Kraft gibt das zu
unterscheiden dann kann man dafür sorgen
dass diese Menschen den Terrorist nicht
zulaufen Fazit für Europa Europa steht
an der Seite Israels aber es macht auch
sehr deutlich dass es die Menschen in
Palästina nicht vergisst danke schön für
diese Information aus Brüssel Ulf Röller
war das auch zahlreiche deutsche
Touristen und Jugendgruppen sitzen in
Israel fest und versuchen auf
verschiedensten Wegen rauszu zu kommen
andere Länder wie Polen Rumänien Italien
Ungarn fliegen seit gestern ihre
Landsleute aus das Auswärtige Amt sagt
sein
krisenreaktionszentrum sei unter
Hochdruck mit Airlines in Kontakt Volker
dutschck
berichtet ein Foto aus glücklicheren
Stunden Jael Forester mit ihren
3jährigen Söhnen Ehemann Simon und ihrer
Mutter der Hinflug zum Familientreffen
in Israel jetzt sitzt die Familie aus
Frankfurt am Main fest lufthans hat den
Rückflug stonniert vom Auswärtigen Amt
bisher kaum Unterstützung ich kann es
einfach überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen
dass man uns hier so alleine lässt und
uns irgendwelche lächerlichen E-Mails
zukommen lässt dass jetzt mal geprüft
wird ob irgendwie ein fairverkehr über
das Mittelmeer eine Möglichkeit
darstellen könnte sie sollen uns einfach
hier mit Flugzeugen wie es auch die
anderen Länder machen rausholen verdammt
ja viele Länder haben inzwischen
regierungsliger geschickt um Landsleute
nach Hause zu bringen Deutschland plant
nach wie vor keine konzertierte
Rückholaktion für rund 100.000 deutsche
Staatsbürger in Israel sagte
Außenministerin bbock dem ZDF wir haben
evakuierungsflüge mit anderen
Fluggesellschaften auf den Weg gebracht
wir haben durch die krisenhotline
diejenigen die am flugughafen sind
konnten sich bei und an uns wenden
Flugverbindungen vermittelt man musste
dann umsteigen bei einigen Strecken ich
verstehe dass das eine furchtbare
Situation ist aber wenn sie 100.000
Anrufe gleichzeitig haben dann müssen
sie prior
seit Tagen sucht auch Thomas Kaufmann
nach Rückflugtickets mit seiner Frau
Jutta und zwei Freunden wollte der
Augenarzt aus Mainz eine Woche durch
Israel reisen die Gruppe fühlt sich im
Stich gelassen ein bisschen schwierig
finde ich die
informations Politik des Auswärtigen
Amtes die Nachrichten sind am Anfang 24
Stunden alt gewesen jetzt sind sie ein
bisschen aktueller also insgesamt fühle
ich mich hier von unseren Behörden und
auch von unserer Fluggesellschaft mit
der wir gebucht haben schlecht
informiert Jael Forester und Thomas
Kaufmann haben jetzt auch mit Hilfe
ihrer Familien in Deutschland Rückflüge
über Griechenland und der Türkei gebucht
ob die auch wirklich starten weiß heute
niemand Angriff auf Israel was bedeutet
das für Deutschland das ist der Titel
eines frontalspezials heute um 21 Uhr
jederzeit informiert sind Sie online auf
ZDF heute damit zu einer Nachricht aus
der Ostsee die Inter national für
Aufsehen sorgt am Sonntag wurde an einer
Gaspipeline zwischen Finnland und
Estland eine Beschädigung entdeckt
woraufhin die Baltic Connector
geschlossen wurde nun sagt die finnische
Regierung es ist wahrscheinlich dass das
Leck auf äußere Einwirkungen zurückgeht
Henner Hebestreit hat
Details seit di Jahren versorgen sich
Finnland und Estland gegenseitig mit Gas
durch die Pipeline Baltic Connector am
frühen Sonntag morgen war der Druck in
der Leitung plötzlich rapide abgefallen
der Gastransport wurde gestoppt auch
eine
telekommunikationsverbindung zwischen
beiden Staaten fiel aus vor wenigen
Stunden wurde nach Angaben von Finnlands
Regierungschef orpo ein Leck gefunden
das nach finnischer Einschätzung keine
natürliche Ursache hat alustavan arvion
mukaan nach unserer Untersuchung konnte
der beobachtete Schaden nicht durch eine
normale Nutzung der Leitung oder durch
Druckschwankungen entstanden sein es ist
wahrscheinlich dass der Schaden durch
äußere Einwirkungen entstanden ist
seit dem russischen Angriff auf die
Ukraine und vor allem nach dem Anschlag
auf die Pipeline northream 2 beobachtet
die Küstenwache des neuen natomitglieds
Finnland die Ostsee zwischen Finnland
und Russland sehr
genau uns ist im Laufe des letzten
Jahres aufgefallen dass die russische
Präsenz in der Ostsee definitiv
zugenommen hat sowohl mit Kriegsschiffen
aber auch mit zivilen
Fahrzeugen mit dem Bau von Baltic
Connector konnte Finnland seine
Abhängigkeit von russischem Gas
reduzieren ob die Leitung durch aktive
Sabotage einer unbekannten Macht
beschädigt wurde ist offen die Nato hat
ihren finnischen und estnischen
Verbündeten Unterstützung
zugesagt nach Deutschland ein Umdenken
in der Migrationspolitik fordert der
Vorsitzende des Sachverständigen Rates
für Integration und Migration Vorländer
die Regierung müsse für schnellere
Verfahren und weniger Bürokratie sorgen
die Niederlande etwa machten es
ukrainischen Flüchtlingen viel leichter
eine Arbeit aufzunehmen dort hätten 70%
von ihnen einen Job in Deutschland nur
18%. wieder gab es Razen und Festnahmen
im sogenannten reichsbürgermilieu es
geht um eine geplante Entführung von
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach und
um vorbereitete Anschläge auf die
Stromversorgung nach
Durchsuchungsmaßnahmen in sechs
Bundesländern wurden mehrere Verdächtige
festgenommen in koblens stehen bereits
seit Mai fünf mutmaßliche Mitglieder der
Gruppe vor Gericht Bahnfahren wird
wieder teurer zumindest teilweise zum
Fahrplanwechsel am 10 Dezember erhört
die Deutsche Bahn einen Teil ihrer
Fahrpreise im Fernverkehr um
durchschnittlich
4,9%. es geht um die flexpreise sowie um
die bahncart 25 unverändert bleiben die
Spar und superparpreise von diesen
bietet die Bahn pro Fahrt ein bestimmtes
Kontingent an
seit knapp 5 Monaten ist die
Filmindustrie in Hollywood weitgehend
lahm gelegt Schauspieler und
Drehbuchautoren sind oder waren im
Streik nun haben aber zumindest die
Drehbuchautoren ihren Arbeitskampf
beendet 99% der Gewerkschaftsmitglieder
stimmten für einen neuen Tarifvertrag
mit den großen Filmstudios Kernpunkte
darin Lohnerhöhungen und Regelungen für
den Einsatz von künstlicher
Intelligenz und jetzt Sport die Fußball
Europameisterschaften 2028 und 2032 sind
vergeben und das im Schnellverfahren bei
jeweils einer Kandidatur war das auch
nicht so schwierig
uefa- Präsident Alexander tfferin
brauchte kaum eine Minute um zu
verkünden die übernächste em also die
nach der Endrunde in Deutschland wird
auf den britischen Inseln stattfinden
die Gastgeberrolle vier Jahre später
teilen sich dann Italien und die
Türkei während Europas Fußball in 5
Jahren wieder im Mutterland des Spiels
zu Gast sein darf kommt vier Jahre
später mit der Türkei ein
turniergastgeber Neuling zum Zuge
flankiert von der Erfahrung aus
[Applaus]
Italien das kann eine wunderbare
Gelegenheit zum Dialog werden mit einer
Nation die sich an der Schwelle zum
Orient
befindet am bosbus steht das atürk
Olympia Stadion für die EM Premiere in 9
Jahren bereit in Italien gibt es dann
zum vierten Mal
Endrundenspiele diestritten Zulassung
russischer juniorenams für europäische
Wettbewerbe ist zumindest aufgeschoben
einen Einstieg der weiblichen und
männlichen U17 Mannschaften in die
bereits laufende em Qualifikation werde
es aus technischen Gründen nicht geben
mehr als 10 Nationen hatten einen boyott
angekündigt die TSG Hoffenheim hat im
Montagsspiel der Fußballbundesliga der
Frauen die Rückkehr an die
Tabellenspitze verpasst durch das 2:2
gegen Bayer
Leverkusen die Schlüsselszene in der
Minute 2:0 führt Leverkusen und dann
dieser faulelfmeter für Bayer doch
kasewska kann tufekovic nicht überwinden
Hoffenheim ist wieder im Spiel nur 4
Minuten später ein abgefälschter Schuss
von Mara Alber der kuriose
anstusstreffer nur noch
ein:2 eine starke Schlussphase der
Gastgeberinnen wird belohnt ereleta
Memeti 2:2 Hoffenheim verpasst zwar die
erneute Tabellenführung rettet aber
einen
Punkt und das war's vom Sport danke
schön bitteschön noch zeigt sich der
Oktober meist außerordentlich mild und
ruhig nur im Norden zieht Regen auf die
Details zum Wetter hat gleich Katja
hornffer Christian sieers spricht im
heutejournal um
21:45 Uhr mit Außenministerin annaalena
berbock und hier übernimmt morgen Mitri
Sirin alles Gute Ihnen einen schönen
Abend noch und auf
[Musik]
bald
guten Abend noch ein paar Tage hält das
goldene Oktoberwetter durch über
Westeuropa und über den westlichen
Mitteleuropa am oberrein stiegen die
Temperaturen heute wieder bis
26° ganz anders sah es an der Oder aus
da waren es nur 13°. die
Nachttemperaturen aktuell sind mild bis
auf 16° geht's runter auf nordernei bis
auf 7° auf der der schwäbischen Alp und
in Süddeutschland ist es meist klar da
kann sich lokal an der Donau oder auch
am bodenseemer etwas Nebel bilden in
Norddeutschland gibt's mehr Wolken und
mehr Wind dafür keinen Nebel der Tag
morgen beginnt erstmal sehr freundlich
aber schon vormittags werden die Wolken
von Norden dichter und spätestens ab den
frühen Nachmittagsstunden kann es dann
in Niedersachsen in schlisswig-holstein
zum Abend dann auch in Mecklenburg
vorpommen auch mal kräftiger regnen bei
einem starken bis stürmischen Wind aus
westsüdwestlichen Richtungen sonst
bleibt's bei viel Sonnenschein und so
liegen morgen die Höchsttemperaturen
meist bei 21 bis 28° nur an den Küsten
bleibt es bei 17 bis 20° Kühler der
Regen von morgen verharrt dann am
Donnerstag über der Mitte Deutschlands
am Freitag wird es von Norden stürmisch
und am Samstag dann für alle deutlich
wechselhafter guten Abend